in 1996 James Marcus became the 55th
employee at amazon.com and its senior
editor Amazonia is his new memoir of the
early years at the startup that boasted
5.3 billion dollars in sales last year
this talk from the KGB bar in New York
City is an hour my name is Tracey chin
from the new press and I'm pleased to
welcome James Marcus author of Amazonia
5 years at the epicenter of the dot-com
juggernaut as some of you may know James
was employed a senior editor at Amazon
from 1996 to 2001 he was also employee
number 55 which is a pretty grand feat
considering there are a thousand
employees at one point his work has
appeared in The Washington Post book
world New York Times Book Review antlia
Atlantic Monthly and other publications
tonight he'll be reading from his book
and I'm sure you'll enjoy his account of
working during the age of Internet you
forea
so without further ado James first I'd
like to thank KGB for having me here and
I'd like to thank everybody for coming
out to listen
looking at the KGB schedule I noticed
that they're often two people here and
that the readings are customarily two
hours long in that space of time I could
read this entire book and probably one
of the shorter Henry James novels so I'm
I'm not going to read quite that long I
think what I will do is read the very
first chapter of the book then make some
comments and remarks and then move on to
a later chapter and I'm you know by
filling in the gaps a little bit in
between the two after that I'd be happy
to field any questions or comments
anybody might have so as I said I'll
just get underway with the first chapter
that's much better
okay um one fine spring day in 1996 I
took off from Portland Oregon in a prop
playing the size of a toy which seemed
to touch down in Seattle only minutes
later at the airport I rented a car then
I drove to a low inauspicious building
south of the downtown next to a barbecue
joint whose vinegar scented fumes like
its smell the moment I hit the sidewalk
and made my way inside since I was there
for a job interview I had donned a
jacket and tie before entering and once
I had the sensation of being the most
formally dressed guy in the building not
to mention the oldest and let's recall
that I was only 37 sufficiently elderly
that is to play father time in Amazon
comes winter pageant to my right sad a
half dozen employees answering phones
and papering their computers and crude
wooden desks with yellow post-it notes
directly in front of me was a
receptionist seated at another crude
wooden desk yet the atmosphere of the
place was so anti-corporate that she
seemed merely decorative and it struck
me that a toddler could have breached
the security cordon are you James a
woman said approaching me I recognized
Susan Benson's voice from our telephone
conversation an East Coast accent with a
slight Californian deceleration at the
end of her sentences she shook my hand
warmly and ushered me into what looked
like the only bona fide office in the
place Jeff she explained would be
interviewing me first and here he was at
this point Jeff Bezos hadn't yet become
a figure out of American folklore and
yet been celebrated as the only beginner
of e-commerce or vilified as a purveyor
of virtual snake oil his explosive laugh
which first erupted about 60 seconds
into our conversation was still an
unknown quantity he was merely a small
sandy haired man seated at a messy desk
reading my clips I like these he said
brandishing the manila folder I like
your first sentences I thanked him
although I had flown we spoke for a
moment about the surprising dullness of
the drive between Portland and Seattle
which tended to peak around the time you
cross the Niska
mudflats I was in the rare an enviable
position of not caring if I got the job
which made me relaxed tie or no tie jeff
was wearing baggy khakis and a blue
oxford shirt and his demeanor was so
low-key that he seemed in some moments
to be moving in a kind of an affable
slow motion he asked me how I would feel
about working 60 hours a week I'm not
wild about the idea I said wondering if
this was the good or bad kind of honesty
but if I love the work I'm doing I don't
think I'd mind as much what I'd like you
to do he said putting these nuts and
bolts matters firmly behind us is to
explain a complicated process in a
simple a manner as possible later I
discovered this was the Bay's own Ian
curveball which in some shape or form
was lobbed at every job candidate in
many cases the trembling applicant was
asked how many gas stations were in the
state of Texas or how many windows there
were in New York City
nobody was expected to cough up the
right answer you were expected to
demonstrate some conceptual shrewdness
and how you arrived at the number though
and I suppose my own answer supplied a
similar window into my mental processes
it was easier of course since Jeff had
let me select my own brainteaser
I chose to explain how I translated the
florid Italian cursing at Oriana Fallaci
cheese novel insha'allah into florida
merican cursing how was that complicated
he asked well usually a word-for-word
translation of an idiomatic expression
doesn't work what sounds blasphemous in
one language sounds dopey in another but
it's simple too in the sense that you
just sit down with a dictionary on a pad
and some sharpened pencils and get it
done one sentence after another
I gave Jeff some examples and he seemed
satisfied with the way I juggled
simplicity and complication laughing at
my potty mouth equivalents for cazzo
ducat so Scott Sato then looking
embarrassed he asked me what my SAT
scores had been I know it's been a while
since you took them he said but if you
could remember at least your approximate
scores I took a guess and here too he
seemed satisfied noting the numbers on a
piece of paper in retrospect this would
be my first taste of the company's mania
for quantification for its immersion in
what was grandly called the culture of
metrics it was obvious that my
performance on those
tests which had taken place a generation
ago had little bearing on my current
abilities still Jeff jotted down my
scores with evident relish would it
bother you to be working for a store
rather than a newspaper or magazine he
said that depends I replied I understand
that you're not running a philanthropic
service here are you selling stuff but
that is the idea that I pretend to like
everything no no not at all he said we'd
be hiring you for your abilities as a
book critic
the idea is to seem smart and
authoritative to become not just a store
but a destination he gave this last word
an almost theological stress we batted
around favorite books for a moment it
turned out that we both had a weak spot
for Frank Herbert's dune trilogy and we
spent a minute or so dissecting the
desert ecology of eraqus and the
sublimely evil bear and her Kannan the
sort of villain who chuckles a lot
then Jeff turned the tables what about
you he said is there something you'd
like to know he leaned back in his chair
and seemed to be girding himself for an
assault he needn't have bothered
I had already succumbed to his brand of
anti Kris Matic charisma which would
have mortified a great man of a century
ago but seemed just right for our nerd
driven meritocracy now Jeff should be
stressed was a likeable and normal
person he had none of Bill Gates's pasty
paranoia nor would he be likely to build
a floating Xanadu in the manner of Larry
Ellison no no doubt he was and is as
ambitious as either of these Empire
builders yet the habit of humorous
self-effacement kept his Napoleonic side
under wraps well yes there is I said
what's a hedge fund according to a Wall
Street Journal article I had read this
had been Jeff's bread and butter a de
Shah and the term meant nothing to me
good question he said sketching a graph
on a piece of scrap paper he explained
that it was possible to track the
diverging and converging fortunes of
certain industries Airlines and oil for
example and once you understood their
peculiar rules of attraction to make
scads of money here he hit the bay zone
Ian's curveball out of the park he made
the mind-bending complexity of running a
hedge fund seem so simple that I thought
I could run run out and start one of my
own
but now jeff has squirted me back
downstairs to Susan we had a great
conversation
and he told her and then asked her to
show me the warehouse although Amazon
had been selling books for less than a
year it had long since outgrown its
original quarters in Jeff's Bellevue
garage and the current location was
basically a warehouse with very ad-hoc
offices Suzan led me down a short
corridor and into a large room with row
upon row of metal shelves on each shelf
was a pile of books the place might have
resembled a library except that each
pile represented an individual order and
if the high Chile room with its Home
Depot Hardware was an impersonal space
the books themselves were all too
personal indeed the more you traveled up
and down the aisles and examine the
rubber-banded merchandise the more you
felt yourself surrounded by Rorschach
plots in one pile stunned all cohabited
with pat the bunny another included
Tolkien a vegan cookbook and a guide to
field stripping and cleaning your 22
rifle it was dispiriting to find a
shrink-wrapped copy of Mein Kampf but at
least somebody else down the aisle was
investing heavily in Wallace Stevens
this being an Internet bookstore there
were plenty of geekish tech manuals Perl
and HTML and C++ seemed to be the
flavors of the month although here and
there you saw an anti diluvian primer on
COBOL or heaven forbid basic clearly
many customers were prepping for the
MCSE exam and clearly many encouraged by
the Blessed anonymity of the online
experience
we're indulging their private pastimes
forget heterosexual plain vanilla porn
of which there was a great deal trotting
up and down the rows with Susan I came
across tutorials on spanking fisting
flogging shagging not to mention a saucy
bit of Victoriana called firt lling the
rediscovered art of erotic hand
manipulation they were books for the man
from NAMBLA there were stashes of
lesbian erotica much of it involving
vampires and motorcycles are both in
cyberspace I could see there was no love
that dare not speak its name instead
there was a refreshing sexual cacophony
which suggested neither Sodom nor
Gomorrah but fantasy equal American
where the pursuit of happiness was a
matter of individual taste trust thyself
every heart vibrates to that iron string
yes Emerson would be spinning in his
grave yet perhaps the world spanning
mind-melding web would itself
offer the best
from what he called the stir in fact the
sad self unrelenting and identical up
and down the aisles we went warehouse
worker circulated around us snatching
from the shelves Dover paperbacks at a
dollar a pop The Cat in the Hat
hölderlin a history of duct tape and I
noticed as Susan led me up many many
copies of Thomas Kuhns the structure of
scientific revolutions the author died
not long before which might have
contributed to a momentary boost in
sales but surely Kuhn sermon on the new
paradigm the process by which one
conception of the universe of plants and
swiftly eradicate sin other had a very
Amazonian ring to it call it wacky call
it hubristic but the employees of what
was then essentially an online catalog
and fulfillment operation were intent on
changing the world their sense of having
grabbed history by the horns was almost
palpable and made them slightly Gideon
enormous ly tired or so it seemed as we
adjourned to the Starbucks world
headquarters across the street where
there was a shiny new cafeteria I'd put
on my jacket as we crossed first Avenue
and once again resembled an evil
businessman sent over from central
casting my future colleagues on the
other hand looked like they were about
to attend a clambake
there was Jonathan a rumpled guy in a
fez who had studied genetic sociobiology
and programming and had written one of
the first books on the Internet a kind
of Mensa poster boy there was Barry
quite literally a rocket scientist who
used to work at the Jet Propulsion lab
down in San Diego and seemed the most
unruffled of the entire crew compared to
these two I felt like a seedy little
humanist but Todd with his shock of
bleached hair and elaborately shabby
clothes was more of a kindred spirit
like me he had gotten a graduate degree
in writing and kept himself just above
or just below the poverty line by dint
of freelance journalism not that I've
been doing much writing of any kind he
said as we carried our trays to the
table
ever since The Wall Street Journal
article came out we've all been swamped
with customer service
Jeff's supposed to be hiring a ton of CS
people until then we have to hold down
the fort
Jonathan daintily rearranged his Fez as
I would later learn he never exposed his
scalp in public what I'm interested in
right
yeah I was collaborative filtering he
told me taking a sip of soda
I've not seen anybody really using the
technology we have let alone what we'll
have in six months we chatted the five
of us and sized each other up Barry said
little although it did come out that
she'd been a National Spelling Bee
champion as a girl
Jonathan delivered and measured Pepsi
field critique of Stephen Jay Gould
whose use of evolutionary history he
found archaic here I was out of my
league but Todd asked me what I thought
of the latest Richard Ford and then
moved on to what would prove to be an
eminently practical question how long
does it take you to write a book review
he asked depends on the length a short
one maybe two hours I said shaving off
the odd minute a longer piece like the
Albert Murray thing I sent Jeff that
could take a day or so how fast could
you review 100 books Todd said I paused
I already understood from my talk with
Jeff that literary criticism in Amazon
would be a wholesale rather than a
retail business still the number was
daunting it sounded less like reviewing
and more like a pie-eating contest but
they were precedents weren't there
Samuel Johnson dictating the Rambler
essays directly to the printer
there was Balzac with his coffee Kerouac
with his speed I chuckled like the
incipient hack I was and said how long
would you like it to take an afternoon
he replied and although we all laughed
it wasn't clear exactly how hyperbolic
his answer was after an obligatory dose
of the brew of the day we headed back
across the street the breeze had shifted
and the barbecue fumes were again in
evidence we shook hands
Susan assured me that she would be in
touch again soon and I found myself on
another flight to Portland to the east
across the isle I could see the tops of
the Cascades to the west the Sun was
setting and for another 15 minutes until
its fiery disappearance behind the
Olympics we were in the midst of a
temporary golden age which made us
squint I ate the pretzel nuggets I'd
found in the seat pouch I mauled over
the day's events I flipped through the
book in my briefcase whose pages
appeared to be gilded by the pyrotechnic
display outside at the time I was
interested in writing an essay and being
Jewish a relatively rare condition
in the Pacific Northwest with his
heftier complement of black bears and
white supremacists and was looking for
material as we approach the Columbia
River I read the following bit from
Martin Buber
the life story of the people after all
is basically nothing more than the life
story of any member of that people in
large projection hmm
this was either a killer insight or an
eerie anticipation of the Me Generation
I wasn't sure which in any case it made
me wonder whether my lunch companions
would be making history on the scale
they imagined and whether I should join
the party if invited I still hadn't
decided when the plane made its final
descent now as should be clear from the
book they did actually get a job there
after a particularly rigorous hiring
process I was called back again to to
interview with the vice president of
marketing who was signing off on all the
editorial hires this was actually an
interesting percent iment of five years
of head-banging between the marketing
department in the editorial department
but I was summoned up there had another
interview and then although I didn't
attend it there was a hiring meeting for
me now I think I'll just deviate this is
not actually in the book but it couldn't
quite fit it in there but the ritual of
hiring and hiring meetings at Amazon was
a world unto itself you have to
understand that you know as was noted
before the company expanded from about
55 people when I started to eight
thousand plus within a couple of years
if you do the math which I have tried to
do that really means you have to be
hiring several people every single day
to get to the right size in two years so
particularly the first few months I was
there I spent an enormous amount of time
interviewing people at Amazon
everybody was interviewed by many many
other people including the people that
the candidate would possibly be bossing
and at the end and then everybody who
had interviewed the candidate would
write down a detailed sort of brochure
what they thought and then there would
be a hiring meeting usually with 10 to
50
people and you would go around the room
and they were I think five different
gradations each person could deliver
from strong higher was the best and then
it was sort of indifferent higher don't
want this person working here I'd sooner
die I can't remember exactly what the
what they were called but um I was in at
least one of these meetings were in fact
the only person in the room who wanted
to hire the candidate was Jeff Bezos who
owned the company and every single other
person said no and to my complete
astonishment he heard the moment allowed
himself to be overruled
so it was a real specimen of workplace
democracy which was a very big deal at
Amazon and I think throughout a lot of
the internet companies at the beginning
of the boom not as much at the end of
the but that's the way it goes anyway at
my hiring meeting which I did not attend
but a friend there later filled me in on
it
which of course is never supposed to
happen he breached the confidential wall
and told me that at the time Amazon was
using a headhunter they would continue
to use a headhunter to hire programmers
which they were desperately in need of I
doubt they ever used another headhunter
to hire an editor or a writer but they
were using a headhunter that and when my
name came up Jeff despite the fact that
we had had a great conversation said who
why who is this guy and the headhunter
said you loved him he was a superstar
now the thing is that Amazon Superstar
was another one of these enchanted words
the fact was that everybody at the
company was supposed to be a superstar
and that also meant that if you hired
somebody you were always supposed to
hire somebody smarter and more capable
than yourself that was the human
resources creative the company now you
know in some philosophically pure
universe that may happen but you know as
we all know at a real corporation nobody
ever hires someone who is smarter or
more capable than themselves so you know
this would but this was nonetheless the
official company creed and so at least
for the duration of my hiring meeting I
was a superstar and I did get hired I
started there in September of 1996
learn the ropes fairly swiftly and in
fact found it easy and immensely
enjoyable to be there I can't stress the
extent to which a company like that was
the seat-of-the-pants operation in 1996
it's it's only eight years ago right but
but it was a mom-and-pop grocery and in
terms of the way it was set up and that
was the fun part of it you really had to
make it all up as you went along but
somebody like myself for example during
my first couple of weeks would be
entrusted to flip the site at the end of
the day meaning that at the time there
was a live site that everybody came to
who was shopping at Amazon and there was
an offline site where all changes would
be made and then at the end of the day
you'd flip them and the new one would be
online now I don't know where that takes
place now but possibly in a reinforce
bunk or somewhere you know within a
clean room or something but at the time
you know any schlep or who was still at
the office at 5:30 was you know pushed
into the office and said here you can
flip the site now and you know again
that made it just a fantastically
interesting and fun place where also you
could leave your mark in a way that you
would never be able to once it attained
full you know late adolescent early
adult status as a giant corporation so
thus did I get started there I think
what I will do now is move on to another
chapter which is somewhat more general
in the sense that it's not so much about
the nuts and bolts of working their day
to day but it is about what was an
enormous and undeniable component of the
whole scenario which was the vast
accumulation of money that was taking
place when I started at Amazon and
negotiated I use that word advisedly
because I am NOT gifted at all not
negotiating and friends you know friends
and family said be tough as nails you
know demand an enormous salary and you
know I had a conversation with Susan
Benson hired me after much internal
preparation saying you know Susan I
imagine taking this job for less than
$50,000 and she said well we can't pay
you that myself whatever and so you know
I got a lower salary than that but the
thing was there was this whole stock
option business now I mean I was an
absolute naive going into this I had no
idea what stock options were I had a
vague idea that that Microsoft employees
became rich by some esoteric mechanism
that I didn't you know how would I know
and on top of that when Susan hired me
she said by the way there was this long
series of caveats she had to put in
prompt me for legal reasons saying the
company may not go public this may not
happen that may not happen these shares
will be worth less than so it was
essentially saying we'll give you a
handful of scrip it might be where we're
sitting or something or not at least
that's how somebody like me comprehended
it I was I just wasn't prepared for the
tsunami of money that that issued for us
from a company like Amazon when it went
public it wasn't the kind of thing you
thought about every day because you
wanted to do your job and if you were at
all honest with yourself you knew there
was some essential disconnect between
whatever fortune you were piling up and
whatever you know review of the latest
John Updike you were writing at your
desk but at Amazon and at every company
like Amazon and indeed throughout the
whole economy during that the Internet
boom of the late 90s this was a very key
sociological piece of the puzzle so the
next chapter I'm going to read is about
my participation and some relevant
family history and just about the whole
you know rather surreal experience of
going from rags to riches and as I say
in the book and then then back to nicer
rags again ok this is the 8th chapter of
the book I have before me 3 100 ruble
notes issued in 1910 each is imprinted
with identical portrait of Catherine the
Great who's got a healthy head of hair a
tiara and a rather neck Sounion hint of
a
five o'clock shadow the Empress is not
smiling the bills are crisp as if
freshly ironed and the ink green black
rose has lost none of its intensity why
nearly a century after they rolled off
the press to these notes look Sonu
well my ancestors sewed entire bundles
of them into the lining of their clothes
when they departed Russia one step ahead
of the Cossacks these closely held
assets rustled in their suits their
vests their top coats shielded from the
elements the Bills made their way from
Odessa to Bucharest than to Belgium
where they would become for some months
in Antwerp while passage was arranged
and then to England from there they
traversed the ocean to New York and
style on the Cunard lines RMS Berengaria
having miraculously invaded thieves and
sticky-fingered immigration officials
they were cut loose from their swaddling
and spilled onto a table in Queens they
were bright increased and consecutively
numbered they were also worthless
there's no use blaming it on my
ancestors as they studied the sizzling
wake behind the ship or waited patiently
on line at Ellis Island to have their
names anglicized they probably didn't
know that the October Revolution had
wiped out their savings they must have
felt prosperous as they walked down the
gangplank and why not they were wearing
the fiscal equivalent of Kevlar next to
their skin history alas has certain
armor-piercing qualities and it was
history not greed or sloppiness or
bullish optimism that pulled the rug out
from under them they didn't deserve to
be paupers still their dalliance with
paper wealth can't help but remind me of
my own I'm going to shed my
chronological straitjacket for a moment
the better to recount how the Internet
boom took me from rags to riches - well
nicer rags as I've noted before I
received 1,000 stock options when I was
hired by Amazon with a strike price of
$1 per share observing some personal
difficulties I was having during my
first few months on the job and quite
frankly out of the goodness of their
hearts my bosses gave me an additional
grant in December meanwhile the stock
split twice before the company even went
public in retrospect ice
the chef's silver-tongued testimony on
behalf of his brainchild had been almost
too effective with the IP oversubscribed
he now needed to increase the size of
the float and create more shares at the
time though I had no idea why such an
event would happen all I knew was that
you got a little slip of paper via
interoffice mail and suddenly you you
had more options it struck me as a
natural process like the propagation of
salt crystals now I had my little heap
of options a few thousand of them
needless to say there was no physical
evidence of any kind not even engraved
certificate of the kind Daddy Warbucks
used to pull out of the safe yet the
shares existed the options rather
existed they represented my minuscule
share of ownership in the company and on
May 15th 1997 when Amazon went public I
suddenly gained several hundred thousand
dollars in paper wealth some of these
shares I owned in the weeks leading up
to the IPO the company had allowed
employees to make advance purchases of
stock since none of these shares had yet
vested nobody could sell them still it
was supposed to be advantageous to snap
up at least part of your grant for tax
related reasons I couldn't quite fathom
so my parents load me a couple of
thousand dollars and I became an
honest-to-god stakeholder as we were
called most of my hoard however remained
in the form of options I could watch
their value rise and fall teeter totter
style on the nifty internet streaming
thing Rebecca had showed me I could make
furtive embarrassing calculations on a
piece of scrap paper then cover up the
figures with a drawing of a little old
man they always drew when I was nervous
at this stage though there was something
fabulously theoretical about the whole
business you had potential riches
platonic riches but you had no cash if
I'd been more flushed perhaps I wouldn't
have felt the contradiction so keenly
but my finances had gotten even shaky er
during the winter persistent illness
sent my wife to the hospital on two
different occasions and Amazon's rather
skimpy and I mean skimpy insurance
package covered only a fraction of the
costs each time I found myself in the
business office at the hospital cobbling
together installment agreements that
could easily take me years to pay off
the account managers young guys who
positively radiated good health were so
reasonable that I felt like crying I
kept shaking their hands
I couldn't stop thanking them all of
that gratitude had a sedating effect on
me for the next few months I did my best
never to think about money I paid my
bills the ones I could and ignored the
rest I charged everything on my last
remaining credit card
I borrowed more money from my friends
promising to repay them out of the
proceeds of my shammiracle stock sales
which is to say I not only built castles
on air but then erected a penthouse and
solarium on top of the castle in this
fashion 1997 dribbled away then
something amazing happened
in November I picked up the telephone
and told my broker I had a broker to
sell a block of shares for me a few days
later fifty three thousand nine hundred
thirteen dollars and twenty cents
materialized in my checking account for
better or worse this phone call
permanently changed my relationship to
money true it much of that cash
vaporiser than the next week as I wrote
checks to friends doctors hospitals
banks and babysitter's yet in some
subtle way which I was reluctant to
admit even to myself that call had
screwed up my basic conception of
getting and spending before I had I did
a job and was paid for it
a simple equation zero-sum game
sometimes I heard more sometimes less
but the sums always seemed at least
vaguely proportionate now that sense of
proportion was gone don't get me wrong I
was delighted glad as Emerson would say
to the brink of fear to have these
arbitrary riches dumped in my lap I
loved my newfound pot of gold the fact
that it had issued for us from a career
as a nickel and dimed journalist made it
all the more precious in paradoxical
still there was something freaky about
the whole train of events and over the
next two years it was going to get a lot
freakier why because we moon now smack
in the middle of the dot-com boom
partaking of in a memorable phrase
coined by kleiner perkins honcho John
doar the greatest legal creation of
wealth in the history of the planet
Amazon share price kept climbing less
than a year after converting my first
batch of options into cash
I had another transubstantiation on my
hands I turned into a millionaire sure
it was all or mostly on paper so what
the stock split three times between June
1998 and September 1999 and after each
split the price continued to levitate
there seemed to be no end to it
when CIBC Oppenheimer analyst Henry
Blodgett said his celebrated target of
$400 per share on December 15th 1998 the
price jumped more than $46 that very day
and hit the stratospheric bullseye just
a few weeks later well there was no end
to it Dores phrase had begun to look
like an understatement at the peak of
the frenzy my remaining options are
worth nine million dollars I can hardly
type such a sentence without a
pre-emptive shudder I can feel a
towering wave a regular tsunami of irony
about to break over my shoulders the
bubble as we all know eventually went
bust what had resembled a cosmic joke
striking it rich is a book reviewer
turned out to be a cosmic joke as as the
price of Amazon stock collapsed locked
up in the form of unvested options which
I couldn't sell most of my fortune
disappeared hold on though for the
moment I'm gonna look resolutely
backward and enjoy the tea of enjoy and
ignore the tear-stained while it busting
to a new mom okay calling dr. Freud that
will make it easier to convey what it
felt like to be among as Todd put it one
day the best paid editorial staff since
the invention of movable type every
happy family is a like Tolstoy famously
observed but what about every rich one
as it turns out there are numerous ways
to react when you stumble into a major
fortune some Amazonians went on buying
binges cars boats clothes art fine wines
real estate jewelry first editions more
real estate one programmer and
harley-davidson enthusiasts strolled
into a taco joint near the office and
loudly announced that he had hit his
lifetime trifecta I've got a hog a house
and a hot tub others prefer to plow
their gains back into a new diversified
portfolio he had your hedge funds in
your tea bills your bond ladders
blue-chip
if you felt even more irrationally
exuberant than usual you could sing some
spare change into the latest IPO telecom
b2b optical fiber and keep your fingers
crossed whatever you did the market kept
behaving like a roman candle so it made
no sense at all to park your cash in
some chicken feed bank account that was
the equivalent of losing money throwing
it out the window you had to keep it
circulating without a little bounce a
touch of Brownian motion the dollars
would go dead on you they were always
the means to some taxable teleological
end which is to say more dollars then
there were the people like me who
essentially behaved as though nothing
had happened oh it was a wonderful
feeling to be relieved of all those
financial pressures yet most of my old
neurotic inhibitions about money
remained perfectly intact we replaced
none of our dilapidated furniture when
the cheapo particleboard table from Ikea
finally busted we threw it away and left
a vacancy like a bald spot in the living
room I still found it difficult to buy a
shirt a watch a compact disc and every
time I pondered a big-ticket purchase I
heard my brother-in-law Chris's voice in
my ear urging me to avoid his dumb and
dumber mistakes this went beyond
indifference I was seeking protective
camouflage the idea wasn't to look poor
only invisible once in a long while I
took a hedonistic plunge
I bought it or managed a lasagna tuxedo
for my sister's wedding
whose upswept lapel seemed designed to
accommodate a bigger wallet and a
beautiful Steven Anderson archtop guitar
mostly though I continued to wear my
underwear with the holes in it not
wanting to identify with a ruling class
even on my way to the shower no doubt
this reluctance on my part had less to
do with thrift then with pathology my
father a research scientist always
taught me to value creativity which he
had over cash which he didn't he was
right of course still there may be
nothing in this world more crushing than
a good lesson taken to heart it made me
suspicious of my own luck this proved to
be prescient in the long run as it so
often does but it also made my lucre
seem filthier than it really was no
wonder I kept my distance from it in any
case I found the ideal setting for
operating as a stealth
plutocrat Seattle had a long custom of
quiet wealth invisible wealth even Bill
Gates the richest man on the planet and
the jewel in the crown of the city's
entrepreneurial mythology followed suit
if he built himself a house as big as
the local Sheraton he had the good taste
very much of it in a hillside I seldom
discuss these matters and never in any
detailed way early on a couple of months
after the company went public my sister
asked me are you a billionaire now I
told her honestly that I wasn't but once
I was I never mentioned the fact to her
nor to my oldest friends who worked as
hard as I did but weren't being rewarded
with such insane sums who simply weren't
dwelling in the same cloud cuckoo-land
as I was an exception at a certain point
I shared a few figures with my parents
in part this was to reassure them that
they would no longer have to prop me up
financially as they had done for so many
years yet I also wanted to prove that I
had made good that I had hit the jackpot
a childish impulse that I feared would
fly right in the face of my father's
ambivalence about material success I
needn't have worried he and prey
embraced my riches with real gusto and
felt that I deserved much much more
during his toast to the happy couple at
my sister's wedding
he digressed for a moment informed the
audience that his son had virtually
created the internet's flagship retailer
and then implored jeff to ante up mr.
Bies Oh surely James should be given a
billion dollars and that by the way that
didn't happen my brother a bass player
with a predictably erratic income
glanced down at the table thrilled and
mortified I perspired like mad into my
fancy tuxedo in fact my father was more
in touch with the spirit of the age than
I was to get to the heart of an epoch
you could safely ignore its statements
of purpose its fiery declarations listen
instead to the questions it asks in 1863
surveying the panoramic misery of
pre-industrial Russia nikolai cherish FC
asked what is to be done in 1997 at
which point the united states was
supposed to be gliding into a radiant
post-industrial future the question of
the moment was who wants to be a
millionaire the answer needless to say
was was ever
buddy but what made the lost world of
the late 90s so extraordinary was that
such wealth seemed feasible not merely
to robber barons but to college students
and taxi drivers waitresses and
pharmacists and postal carriers plenty
of people most people we're still
scraping to pay their bills the rich
were undeniably getting richer yet the
arbitrary nature of the boom and the way
it plucked its beneficiaries from all
corners of the economic map did suggest
a certain leveling of the field egged on
by regis philbin every american could
now dwell in possibility until that is
March 10th of 2000 on that date the
Nasdaq hit its all-time high closing out
the day at 5,000 48.62 and then
commenced a long ruinous slide which
would eventually siphon three point
eight trillion dollars from our
collective pockets most Amazonians were
slow to panic we had already seen the
stock take a beating on several
occasions and then staged a miraculous
recovery and despite the sputtering
economy all the signs pointed toward a
blowout holiday season and the course of
which Amazon was primed to move more
than a billion dollars worth of
merchandise surely we would ride out the
storm in fact the company might even
benefit from a little calling and enter
the year as the ultimate dot-com
survivor now no matter over the next 18
months amazon shares went into a swoon
they never quite descended into penny
stock hell we're quite a few heavy
hitters of the internet revolution
struggled to warn themselves around the
fire still my options lost more than 95
percent of their value before they
stabilized and began to claw their way
back upward in the interim I sold
several blocks of stock and what I once
would have regarded as absurdly low fire
sale prices hadn't I already lost enough
money due to my touching complacent
loyal greedy quasi religious faith that
the company would always bounce back I
had been foolish I swore but now I would
be a realist in fact I was being foolish
again as I write these words the value
of the shares has now multiplied tenfold
since they touched bottom but this extra
ironic rotation of the Wheel of Fortune
is more than I can deal with at the
moment
in any case by the time I return to
Manhattan from
Seattle in September of 2001 my sister
was no longer asking if I was a
millionaire but if she had I could have
told her honestly that I wasn't it's not
as they say tragedy my fortune
materialized I'd have avoid without any
special effort or ingenuity on my part
and vanished in no less capricious a
manner I made out okay more than okay
the money I squeezed out of the stock on
the way up allowed me to move back east
buy an apartment prepare some sort of
launching pad for the next stage of my
life from time to time
still I have these twinges of regret I
find myself staring at those very items
I was too superior to covet back when I
could afford them a silver Mercedes Benz
a black leather chaise longue a Rodin
this famous bust of Gustav Mahler that I
saw in a shop window near my dentist I
also dream of a little bungalow I
thought of buying during my next to last
summer in Seattle the entrance took you
through a gate and down the steep
western slope of Queen Anne Hill with
fir trees and bright green underbrush on
both sides of the path during the dry
months anyway it felt like an enchanted
forest and at the bottom of this
charming declivity was the house itself
compact and cozy the price of this
picturesque growling was $500,000 a
ridiculous sum I thought yet now that
I'm back in Manhattan where that kind of
money gets you an outhouse with cooking
privileges the bungalow seems more and
more something out of a fairy tale one I
actually participated in what I asked
myself is the moral of the story am I
overlooking some basic lesson about
money and corruption and mild-mannered
hubris I'm not sure what I have decided
is to stop thinking about the Golden Age
which turned out to be largely a matter
of iron pyrites and move on now here too
there are certain lessons to be drawn
from my family history with its patterns
of Yiddish accented peripeteia what for
example became of my great grandfather
Abraham Felder who sewed all that
Czarist currency into his clothing and
once he hooked up with his
brother-in-law who had emigrated some
years before and set up as a diamond
merchant together they founded what was
then a cutting-edge business the Roaring
Twenties equivalent of online
selling jewelry by mail water they made
pots of money more than enough to
compensate for Abraham's defunct rubles
true they were living in a midst of a
major boom President Coolidge himself
anointed it a new era of prosperity when
it was supposedly impossible not to make
money so they went with the flow when
they became rich men by 1925 it was time
to move to a tonier neighborhood they
left Queens for Brooklyn for Flatbush
more precisely which was then an
upper-middle-class citadel they bought a
mansion on Bedford Avenue cheek by jowl
with a country club and there my father
spent much of his childhood each morning
a chauffeured Packard conveyed them to
their offices on Bleecker Street the
driver to who my ancestors early
practitioners of trickle-down economics
gave a motorcycle sat in the car all day
wrapping himself in a blanket when the
temperature dropped penny drove them
home again at the end of the day not
surprisingly Abraham and his partner
developed a healthy disdain for
alarmists defeatist the faint of heart
having escaped catastrophe by the skin
of their teeth back in Russia they now
excluded its very possibility they had
traded those rubles wastepaper play
money confetti for solid American
currency hadn't they their future was
assured they weren't speculators after
all fooling around with intangibles they
dealt in precious stones objects he
could hold in your hand were they
selling costume jewelry or the real
thing I asked my father
nobody knows he told me approached by
their own nephew to at least buy some
life insurance they declined insurance
policies are for poor people they
informed him were set for life
pragmatist they also turned up their
noses at various other pie-in-the-sky
prospects an opportunity arose to invest
in shares of the nascent Trans World
Airlines the whole concept made them
suspicious no whimsical chagall like
dreams of flight for these Jews nobody
will ever fly from one coast to another
in an airplane was their final judgment
how easy in retrospect to see what they
did not that catastrophe was part and
parcel of the universe they should have
known and not only because they left
Odessa in such a hurry catastrophe was
in the air the
even the Berengaria the steel helmed
vehicle of salvation that carried them
from the old world to the new with its
swimming pool Turkish baths and on the
promenade deck an actual brokerage
office for stock trades even the baron
gari itself was a kind of dividend paid
on a previous disaster it had been given
to Cunard by the Hamburg American line
after World War one as compensation for
the Lusitania destroyed by a German
torpedo on May 7th 1915 with a yawning
gash in its starboard hull the ship had
sunk in a mere 20 minutes that left
little time to deploy the lifeboats and
1198 passengers drowned in the Atlantic
the calculus of such a disaster is
unbearable the very arithmetic an insult
compared to those unlucky souls Abraham
and his partner lost nothing when the
economy collapsed in 1929 as they
thought though they had lost everything
the business dried up their investments
went south
the driver was let go somehow they held
onto the house on Bedford Avenue
but even that function to something of a
goad reminding them that it was better
never to have money as they tirelessly
noted then to have it and lose it as the
depression deepened and grew more
desperate they took to sitting in the
parlor every every evening with the
lights out silent and embittered from
time to time they broke the silence in
order to blame each other it's your
fault I'm poor now mostly though they
kept quiet in such a state they refused
to think much about the future which had
seemed to issue them certain promises
certain obligations and had now
defaulted on them my father then a boy
observed all this the dark room the
chastened furious partners he may have
decided then on instinct that cash was a
dubious foundation for the good life in
any case he passed that believed on to
me along with those 100 ruble notes the
secret to keeping money fresh it turns
out is to never spend it as for me I had
other catastrophes to reckon with a week
after leaving Amazon and returning to
New York
I dropped my son off at school in the
morning walked east along great Jones
Street and heard as I approached the
intersection of Lafayette what sounded
like a military jet passing directly
overhead going
there was a loud roar the kind you could
feel in the soles of your feet some
stunt I thought but it was as we all
know a passenger plane and 30 seconds
later everything changed no less
decisively than it had when that torpedo
struck the Lusitania it was tears in my
eyes I stood in the midst of a furious
chastened crowd on the corner and
watched the towers burned in the
distance I thought I saw tiny pieces of
paper floating in the air like confetti
but this was a trick of perspective
these were big sheets of metal or glass
or gypsum board carried aloft by the
updraft that evening I found myself at
an outdoor restaurant on the Upper East
Side the place was jammed and the
funeral hush of the afternoon had been
broken in fact there was a peculiar
energy in the air a sense of expectancy
as if we were all waiting for a verdict
to be announced people joked argued
struggled to regain their conversational
footing if you squinted this could
almost pass for normal life a man at the
next table sent back his and Eve salad
as a procession of enormous refrigerator
trucks dodged potholes on their way
downtown anybody could figure out what
the trucks were for I did and my lost
riches which had already ranked pretty
low on the scale of terrible events
dwindled to microscopic size then
vanished I wish I could say that I never
thought of them again yet I do the
ordinary heartbreak says nadejda mondal
storm called them the non catastrophic
ones are sometimes trivial and sometimes
not in either case they're impressively
tenacious in the evenings as my
ancestors did I lapse into the
occasional reverie about my monetary
rise and fall I've made it a habit
however to always leave the lights on
thank you
now I see we have you know 10 or 15
minutes left if there if there are any
questions of any stripe I'd be happy to
answer them there's a gentleman with a
boom over here so I guess the question
are supposed to talk into the boom or if
not not but anybody do you have a
question oh okay
I was wondering that's the entire time I
was reading a book it's the bird loosely
based on a real person at all I know you
said that it was a composite but just
curious no that's understandable the
bird I should explain to anyone who
hasn't heard the book I mean this is a
nonfiction book and it didn't change
anybody's names you know all the
dialogue and the incidents are real but
I did insert one composite character
which I admitted at the time I did it so
it wasn't as though you didn't know and
I'd have to say that she has a composite
character there are pieces of her which
will no doubt be recognized by some of
the donors maybe not in a completely
happy way but she has a genuine
composite I did actually have one funny
experience with that quite a few but one
of them was that when the book was done
the publisher has happens with many a
non-fiction book gave it a legal read
had an attorney read through it to make
sure there was nothing actionable he
found nothing wrong with it at all with
one exception apparently he had
forgotten that the bird was a composite
so this one problem was some insulting
comments directed at this composite
character everything else was okay
luckily that person will not be suing me
under any circumstances so yes it is a
composite and amusingly some various
colleagues former colleagues from Amazon
who
emailed me since the book came out and
they read it all seem to have their own
obvious choice for who who it really is
and the last one suggested me was
somebody in fact I'd never met so she's
a true composite and I had so much fun
playing with her that it was an
inspiration to write an all composite
which is a fiction book after this one
so that's what I'm doing now wait for
the boom did you end up reviewing in an
afternoon
that's that that's the number I haven't
quite tabulated yet the thing was I know
as I described in the book I mean what
am I supposed to my first reviewing
assignment there which was maybe my
first day or my second day there at
which point I was really learning the
software I wasn't starting my duties as
the Edmund Wilson of amazon.com eeeh but
Patrick O'Brien was then about to
publish the latest installment of his
you know maritime epic which eventually
ran to 21 volumes this was probably this
I don't remember what it's in here thing
it was the 17th or something so Susan
who had hired me came into the office
with the preceding 16 volumes in
paperback put him on my desk and said oh
the new one is coming out we need
reviews of all of these now and today we
need them this afternoon actually so
this was at a point actually we're not
first of all you didn't sign your name
to any of these things
there was really no editorial operation
to speak of yet and clearly what and in
fact what the company had been using in
many cases was simply flap copy from the
book because there really was no
editorial department there was nobody to
write things so she wanted something one
step up the critical food chain from
that so I sat down did some really
edifying flipping for a few hours talk
to somebody at my office mate he had
read the books so hey that was almost
like reading away I talked to someone
who read them and then you know I wrote
whatever my 16 paragraphs they are not
bits of writing I
would like collect in a book if I ever
you know did a book of criticism but it
was also very clear to me that I wasn't
signing these things and so in a way I
thought okay this is sort of a
copywriting job
so that was a t1 i I believe that once
the conventional operation of a head of
an editorial department got going I was
supposed to do I think eight books a
month that was on top of my normal
duties and it wasn't as though you
weren't supposed to sit on reading at
work forget it
I had many other duties I was doing
because I edited the home page I worked
on the co-editor of a literature and
fiction page and of those eight some of
them could be older books that I had
read already but it was you know we had
there was an effort to beef up the
catalogue basically so you know eight
that's whatever that it comes out to 96
books a year I reviewed hundreds of
books while I was there but I haven't
had the heart to quite add it all up and
plus thousands of other pieces of copy
you know little blurbs and interviews
and features and so as an enormous
amount of writing but I don't know
exactly how many reviews there were at
the end
yes I could not understand why at
certain times the company asked you to
start packing books for shipment and all
that you at the U as well as other
editors mm-hmm we're probably better
paid than the Packers it would have been
cheaper to get the Packers and you
probably were not as good as packing the
books as those guys both of those
statements are true actually well it was
it so many Gally Terry on exercise I
think it was a combination I think there
was an egalitarian impulse of the kind I
mentioned before where there was this
notion that this was not a traditional
corporation there was not the high and
the mighty and the low there were
everybody in the middle but there was
actually a pragmatic reason for that
which is that now basically every single
non-essential personnel and the company
had to go to the warehouse and work
their first period of several weeks
around the holidays but the thing was
let's just take Seattle because Amazon
had warehouse is in Fernley Nevada New
Castle Delaware they had one I think in
George God knows where else but even in
Seattle what it meant was just as the
business for the year was peaking
because Amazon like most retailers does
a disproportionate share of its business
during the holidays just as that was
peaking you could throw several hundred
warm bodies into the warehouse and have
them work 10-hour shifts you didn't want
to hire those people through regular
channels because you didn't I mean for
one thing they didn't they didn't need
those people the rest of the year and so
they were there on tap but eventually
hundreds of them were flown out to these
other godforsaken places where they
weren't even taking books there they
were out a cherry picker removing a
giant TV from a bin 30 feet above the
floor so I think it was a combination of
a cultural revolution where everybody
had to get their hands dirty and what
was essentially you know the shock
troops of the labor force that they
could just throw in in some of these
other places where Amazon open these
warehouses it's I got the impression
they had sucked dry the labor market by
the time the holiday season game and so
they had to throw everybody else in
there
as editors there was a certain
fascination to it for a little while and
you did remind you what the company was
doing after all but you know we all felt
after a certain point we maybe we could
have been more effective selling books
as editors doing the site but we were
told no in fact that's your job for now
is it go to the warehouse at two o'clock
in the morning you know have someone in
an orange vest sign UN and then wheel a
library card around for 10 hours
removing books from the shelf
yelling them over to somebody else you
know or whatever your job was so it was
a combination of practical necessity and
I think workplace democracy and I will
say that you saw you know Jeff Bezos you
saw all the top brass there I don't know
if they were there day and night but
they always you know put it in
appearance so it limited you know how
much moaning and groaning you could do
not entirely but it let me do it a
little bit yes how did your job change
over the years
well when I started at Amazon of course
it was totally unclear what the job was
going to be you know they wanted to hire
me as an editor it's a kind of a thing
in the book where I said to citizen so
what's my job title and she said well
you'll be an editor but we'll think of
you as an editor extraordinaire I mean
that sounded good but the thing was
everybody was an editor even I mean it
no matter what you had been in your
previous life if you had never worked in
a job before if you could fog up a
mirror you could be an editor at Amazon
basically I mean which isn't that many
of them were very very talented and
turned out to be tremendously good
editors and some of them came from you
know great editorial births before that
but initially as things settled in a
little bit my job was to write book
reviews interview authors because when I
started there was a robotic thing where
any author could go to a certain URL and
there would be questions you could enter
them into fields and you would have in
effect an online interview but this was
cookie cutter style everybody had the
same interview and not surprisingly it
was mostly very little-known authors who
did it because they couldn't get
publicity in any other way as soon as I
got there I you know I said to Susan
couldn't we interview authors like at a
publication like I had done before that
she said fine you know why you set one
up I said this first one up which was
actually was Scott Turow cuz he had a
new book coming out I went into Susan's
office and said Susan do we have like a
template for this or you know the way
these things are set up so I could look
at it before and she said no you'll just
have to make it up do the HTML yourself
so you know I did it wasn't that hard
really as time went by there was a kind
of a time lapse development extremely
accelerated there where for about two
years two and a half years Amazon had
enormous editorial ambitions they hired
dozens and dozens of editors just the
book department probably had 25 editors
I mean which is more than many national
magazines have a huge pool of
freelancers the company was spending
millions of dollars a year on
freelance writers and so at that point
the job sort of moved closer and closer
to being like working at a magazine
almost and the great thing was you could
assign yourself to do almost anything
you wanted I also then got this job
writing and editing Amazon's home page
which was the page you know if you typed
in WW Amazon com you went there it was
the point of entry for most customers I
picked the book to be featured there
wrote the copy and that was a very
exciting and interesting job - suddenly
though about two-and-a-half years into
it somebody at the company woke up and
said one morning gee we're paying a lot
of money to these people and they're not
earning enough money in return I mean
the dispiriting thing was at a place
like Amazon if you interviewed Tony
Morrison they could track exactly how
many people bought Toni Morrison's book
after reading your interview and often
that wasn't new as you wanted to know as
the writer so there was this there was a
huge backpedaling then and a feeling
that we shouldn't be as much of a big
editorial operation those things started
to be cut back the editors were
encouraged to leave or were fired and
the you know the vacancies they left
behind were filled in by automation
which meant that the site would
automatically select what book you
should see rather than having a human
being do it and also by customer reviews
which you know had always been one of
Amazon's novelties and great drawing
cards but again perhaps that same day
that person woke up on that side of the
bed and said you know we have a choice
we can continue to pay top dollar to you
know 50 editors and God knows how many
freelancers or we can turn to three or
four hundred thousand customers who will
do it for nothing now you know on a from
a business point of view it's not hard
to predict the the outcome there so
essentially by the time I left my job
had been you know on one side automated
out of existence and on the other side
you know we had all become sort of
bootblacks to the customer reviewers and
that was not a satisfying position for
me
so that led to my exit directly one more
question okay anybody I'm curious what
you miss most about your time there I
think what I miss most is the atmosphere
I was describing at the very beginning
which is to say really the first two
years it's very good for me it's very
good for my sort of mental health and
self-respect that I do not work at
Amazon anymore I mean because if you had
serious ambitions as a like a critic and
a writer eventually a certain corrosion
would set in and it was you couldn't
deal with it but it was so exciting at
the beginning and nobody knew it was
gonna happen there was this sense of
explosive growth and open-endedness and
you know I like to feel that this book
and the books I plan to write after it
will ultimately be much more worthy
accomplishments than my having worked at
Amazon but I will never be in another
job environment that you know gave you
that daily jolt of being in a brave new
world and I suppose that's what I miss
the most so thank you everybody very
much for listening
James Marcos was senior editor at
amazon.com from 1996 to 2001 Amazonia is
published by new press visit the new
press comm for more information
[Music]